[Musik]
rauchende Meiller beißende Luftkühler
und war früher ein Knochenjob und er ist
es auch heute noch ich bin heute mal für
die Drecksarbeit zuständig bin nämlich
unter die Köhler gegangen und mache
heute aus Holzkohle das sind nicht nur
genauso aus wie vor hunderten von Jahren
es wird auch noch genauso gemacht und
warum die letzten ihrer Zunft so an
ihrem Aussterben im Handwerk festhalten
das finde ich heute mal tatkräftig
heraus
wie man aus Holzkohle macht ist eine der
ältesten Handwerkstechniken der
Menschheit
ohne die Köhler und ihre Holzkohle Handy
Menschen nie gelernt aus Erz Eisen
herzustellen wo es viel Erdgas gab es
also auch viele Köhler wie hier im Harz
ein Mittelgebirge mitten in Deutschland
ich besuche die fällt mehr als eine der
letzten Köhler Familie
wir wollen halt die Tradition erhalten
zeigen wie das Leben im Harz damals hier
so stattgefunden hat von der Holzkohle
bis zum Erzabbau bis zum Schmied hat
kein Material geschafft sie ganz normale
Flamme vom Holz vom Feuer schafft es
nicht Eisen zu schmelzen am auch
mindestens doppelte Heizkraft und das
schaffst du nur die Holzkohle damals und
wenn du Lust hast kannst du das alles
nachher mal mitmachen
[Musik]
einer muss ja die Erde drauf halten ist
doch nicht da rein rutschen und dann
wird der zugeschaut werden werde und
dann liegt da ein großer Erdhaufen
Erdmann
angezündet mit
Sauerstoff versorgen
ohne köhlerhandwerk
gebe gar kein Eisen es gäbe keinen
Bergbau die Schmiede hätten wir kein
Material und Werkzeuge herzustellen als
Stunde riesenrolle am menschlichen
Entwicklung schon allein Holzkohle zu
haben also die Köhler mussten die
Holzkohle herstellen nur allein um Eisen
zu produzieren zu bearbeiten
[Musik]
eigener schlagen Mensch auch früher also
weil das sind
also so eigene Haar Waldschrat ja schon
selbst mitgekriegt was der endlichen
ganzen Tag gemacht hat dass sie auch
mitnehmen Wald lebte bei den Meiler
Plätzen bei den Code Plätzen also war
natürlich auch mein Schatz ich gar nicht
in die drauf und Köhler so einer bin ich
jetzt
Kohlmeise zum Grillen verwendet
meine erste selbst geerntete Holzkohle